foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar gibco
cell culture Heroes 60th anniversary
edition and I am Susie Valdez of
labroots and I will be your MC for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by labroots and
brought to you by Thermo Fisher
Scientific to learn more you can go
visit them at thermofisher.com now we
encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you might have
during this presentation to do so simply
type them in to the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation you may also submit
any technical issues here as well if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation I'd now like to introduce
Kate Judd who will be moderating today's
panel Kate over to you
hi good morning everybody good afternoon
this is a wonderful webinar we've got
today we're very excited to be here my
name is Kate Judd and I've been with
gibco and thermal Fisher for 21 years I
have a love for gibco so I was very
happy to be a part of this we've got
some great panelists here who have some
wonderful stories I am a marketing I'm
sorry pardon me I am a technical sales
specialist manager in our cell biology
business unit and I am based in Grand
Island New York where our gibco site is
um prior to this role I was in marketing
and prior to marketing I was in our r d
that combinates to 21 years here at
gibco in all parts of our our cell
biology business unit and very happy to
be here we have first we would like to
play a recap of a couple of really cool
video clips from what we've been doing
this year to celebrate our 60 years of
gibco so if we could play that video
well thank you
it all started with a bottle
and you I came to understand how many
Innovations can be discovered by taking
these risks and how much I could
actually learn through the failures the
real skill is discovering why something
isn't working and how you can get it to
work
this is what drives me and what is
important to me that real life impact
and maybe my little cell cultures can
have just that
meeting a future Mentor a chance
encounter at a trade show
touching thank you email
the past six decades have been filled
with your pivotal moments turning points
that have not only taken careers forward
but cell culture as a whole for 60 years
gibco cell culture has been empowering
moments just like these and driving
discovery
our products have been playing their
part in your ups and downs your
breakthroughs and setbacks and now as
this anniversary year comes to a close
we stand back and take a look at just
How Far We've Come Together snapshot in
a bottle is a celebration of our
community our stories and our shared
love for ourselves after all we've only
reached this incredible Milestone
because of you
for the last 12 months we've been
writing our Collective cell culture
history minute by minute we've been
paying tribute to the smaller yet no
less significant pieces that make up the
bigger picture your snapshots
we've heard how a relative's diagnosis
shifted Focus onto cancer research
how a budding scientist felt the first
time working with real patient cells
and how a last-minute leap of faith led
to a fresh start and a dream fulfilled
what do I have to lose right
we've also brought our community
together
staging anniversary events worldwide we
invited Thermo Fisher Scientific
colleagues and customers past and
present to come along reminisce and
raise a toast to an extraordinary 60
years
so here's to the history here's to the
triumphs from the first cultured stem
cells of the 1960s to the covid-19
vaccines of the 2020s
and here's to the millions of defining
moments that have yet to shape our cell
culture Journey
we can't wait to see what the next
chapter has in store for cell culture
and you
all right wonderful
we're very excited about those videos
we've we've done a lot this year and one
of the best parts about it is meeting
scientists
um like you on this panel I would like
to introduce everyone
um I'll meet if you could tell us a
little bit about yourself I'm going to
put you on the spot first
hi
uh can you see me yes sorry the fire the
fire alarm testing went off at the exact
same time
you know building it's the first
Wednesday of the month
but uh hello everybody and my name is
Amit and uh I'm a research scientist at
the University of Cincinnati I work with
Dr Laura Conforti in the department of
internal medicine and I have been a part
of this lab I started as a postdoc then
I became a research associate now I'm a
research scientist uh I have been
working in this lab for the past 12
years prior to this I did my PhD at
Wright State University in physiology
and cell biology
uh and I was there from the years 2001
until 2000 and uh sorry 2003 to 2009 and
before that I have a very interesting
background I have a degree in medicine
from India and I worked for a couple of
years in rural areas as a
practicing physician but my my interest
always uh late in basic science research
so that basically made me come to us and
I have been on a journey the focus of my
research here is mainly cancer research
we study uh head and neck cancer and we
are trying to study what is the
we are basically trying to study what is
the effect of the tumor micro
environment on the immune response and
for that we use primary cell culture
models and we also use the the
commercially available cell culture and
for that I have had a very long-standing
uh relationship with gibco and I am
excited to be a part of this and I'm
looking forward to talking to all of you
thank you
wonderful it's great to meet you too
all right can I put Ernesto on the spot
to go next to introduce yourself
hi hi Kate Hi everyone
um well it's a pleasure to be here so my
name is Ernesto Galore and I'm a postdoc
research Associated at the University of
Sao Paulo at the human genome and stem
cell research center Sao Paulo Brazil
and uh 14 years and well unfortunately
uh lost my uncle due to a liver disease
and since then I decided to dedicate my
entire scientific career trying to
develop new approaches to address this
very relevant issue that is organ
shortage for transplantation
on the beginning of my scientific career
I went to U.S at Temple University the
part of bioengineering working with Dr
Peter Little Krishna and since then I
started to develop several works with
cell culture especially with liver
tissue engineering and then I moved back
to Brazil to do my PhD and most recently
engaged with this uh postdoc research
project in which I shift a little bit
the strategy that I've been using so far
towards a genetic engineering approach
trying to make Universal cell donors
from stem cells and also uh the same
idea but for xenotransplantation which
is we are genetically engineering pigs
to make their organs compatible with
human transplants so yeah that's it
thank you it's a pleasure to be here
nice
getting rid of that wait list right or
the waiting time I love it
um
all right and Rukia will put you on the
spot now to introduce yourself
hello good morning or good afternoon
from where everyone is visiting my name
is Rukia Henry and I am currently a PhD
candidate at workers University but
before coming here how I attended
covered University and that is where my
research some interest began budding
um I conducted a lot of neurovyology
research looking at the bonuses of viral
infections and how it can impact the
brain development and then around my
senior year my mom was diagnosed with
breast cancer and so I decided to go to
graduate school and pursue a degree in
cancer pharmacology and So currently I
work in the lab of Dr srid arganisan and
my work entails a lot of cell culture
which is why I was
first introduced to gibco
um one of my projects looks at the Whey
proteins are involved in the DNA damage
response and how the deregulation of
those proteins can cause cancer another
project that I work on
looks at breast cancer and why some
patients do not respond to chemotherapy
and so we're trying to find the markers
that basically show chemo resistant
breast cancers and how we can overcome
that
um and so I am really happy to be
collaborating with gibco because in the
lab I do a lot of cell culture and use a
lot of their resources so it's been a
great pleasure it's a collaborating to
be here today
we're so happy to have you
thank you all right
so if we have everyone visible we've got
our panel session uh I do want to call
out Jessica Hess unfortunately was
unable to make it today due to illness
so we we do miss her but we do have some
great questions for the three panelists
I will
go around the first question I would
love to ask can you have
um one adjective that you would use to
describe gibco
so Amit do you have one word One
adjective
sorry
okay I don't know exactly if it's an
adjective but the one word that always
comes to my mind is supportive
like whatever I needed whatever I wanted
kepco has always been there for me and
sometimes for difficult models uh gibco
has always helped me with excellent tech
support they have provided me with
samples to try new things and whatever
questions I had they always reply to me
so it just made the whole process
uh so easy for me so I would say
supportive supports us it's my support
system and supportive all right good one
all right Ernesto one word for you
if it's possible one word yeah
yeah it's it's a tricky one but I'll go
with Excellency I I think in the more
broader sense of it uh like and it said
uh does the tech support is is fantastic
but also the quality of the products and
services that give Co providers so it's
basically Excellency in a 360 Degrees
manner of speaking Yeah
all right and we're here how about you
you know my word is the same as Amit um
the first thing that I think of when I
hear gibco is supportive and I think
because most of my research is
on Cell culture so whenever I needed
resources of course gibco is always the
brand that we go for if I have questions
or troubleshooting similar to his
experience the technical support is
always there ready to answer questions
walk me through
um the troubleshooting experience and
then even their support throughout my
PhD journey and helping to create even
this network and
I think there's some support none
that's wonderful to hear because we we
pride ourselves on support it's
wonderful to hear that um
all right so we've got another question
I'm going to ask you Rukia first
describe the moment you realize the
importance of cell culture in your own
research experience for example was it
your first cell culture experiment or a
Discovery at the lab what was that
moment you realized
I think for me it was when I started
making
um cell lines from patient tumors and I
realized the value in what I was doing
and the fact that I can take
um tissue that came from a patient's
breast who had breast cancer and then
through a process and made that into a
cell like where I can look at that under
a microscope and then do
um Works more experiments to figure out
what exactly is driving this cancer
um I think that was the defining moment
because of course
it's
such a great opportunity for exploration
um and you're able to get answers to
questions that you might not have in the
moment and then you're able to create
therapies for these patients
um and so I think that was a real
defining moment where the work that I
was doing was directly translational and
cell culture was helping me to
accomplish this
feeling yeah
okay Ernesto how about you your moment
well I think uh my defining moment was
um when I was starting my training on
tissue engineering at Temple University
and then I was trying to to understand
how could I uh produce a human liver in
the laboratory so to do that of course
we need cells
so at the time I did not have any
training on Cell culture so my first
experiment with uh subculture was with
primary human fiberglass very basic cell
culture and this was very interesting
for me coming from a pharmaceutical
background to see themselves growing and
the potential that those cells have to
uh to differentiate to to growth and
possibly in the near future to generate
a fully functional human organ or tissue
that was the defining moment for me
yeah and then to see it in real life too
under a scope too I remember that same
feeling this is right here it's tangible
okay Amit how about you what about your
defining moment
I started cell culture in very simpler
times basically my project during my PhD
was to look at the lens epithelial cells
and we had a lens epithelial cell line
and my thing was to just expose that to
UV radiation and different Pro apoptotic
stimulus and look at the mechanism of
apoptosis so my project was basically to
try to kill cells and I was trying
different methods to kill the cells you
know and looking at the apoptotic assays
so in order to look at large throughput
it was so amazing to discover the
immortalized cell lines in which you
could just grow them in uh 24 well
plates or 96 well plates you can do
different treatments and you can get a
lot of
like you can answer a lot of questions
at once you know you can do a dose
response you can do time response so it
was a revelation for me that okay this
makes things so much easier to find
answers to your question then when I
joined my postdoc we saw I switched to
cancer research and started studying the
immune cells and we started isolating
immune cells from cancer patients or
healthy donors you know and
so I I had to maintain them in cell
culture and then slowly we progressed to
Growing uh two dimensional and sorry
three-dimensional models from primary
tumors you know we grew them into
spheroids and organoids so that was
again an experience so cell culture is
very has been very indispensable for me
I mean I cannot separate cell culture
from my actual research I mean they just
are a part and parcel and an integral
part so
it's just been uh at the Forefront of
whatever I do cell culture so
love it
all right I'm gonna stay with you and
meet for the next question
name one discovery that you would hope
cell culture research can uncover in the
next decade
just one definitely uh over the past
just one uh I think it would uh mainly
be to create a
a model to study
generalized all kinds of cancers
basically like an artificial model which
would be characteristic or have some
kind of a characteristic of different
type of cancers that can be studied in
one model system where you can apply a
lot of techniques and
you can provide answers that's what I
think
that's a good one yeah and I know
because cancer is so and I know you all
have this experience too it's just it's
so many different things it's not just
one disease right so you can pick and
choose pieces or or types right but
um that ultimate goal to hit to hit all
of the types
all right uh Ernesto how about you one
Discovery and I was being funny you
could have more than one but your top
choice I guess your one discovery that
you hope comes in in a decade
well I I really have high hopes that um
with the recent developments on genetic
engineering site combined with Advanced
cell culture techniques we will be able
in the next 10 years to generate uh
genetic engineer cell lines that could
potentially overcome uh the defects of
organ uh donors and tissue donors to
make them compatible universally
throughout the human population and it's
a very diverse genetic background so
that's something that I can I believe
it's it's accomplishable in the next 10
years
how about you
mom I think maybe personal to my project
a model to study the mechanism of
resistance
um to cancer therapies because as much
as we try to uncover the mechanisms that
might drive cancer when you do
treatments a lot of times these cells
can evade it so if we have a model that
can maybe predict what that evasion
mechanism could be in real time it would
make you know cancer research and Drug
Discovery so much easier
and and also how different it is from
Human to human right and we know it's
not going to be the same across the
board so what are those differences too
what are the leading
the causes of those differences too
absolutely yeah
all right so okay do you know uh also
something oh no please I have another
thing you know on a lighter on a lighter
note uh have you seen recent reports
that they have grown a salmon in cell
culture
like salmon meat they grew in cell
culture dish
so I think so what about in the next 10
years if your entire Thanksgiving meal
is grown with cell culture because they
are now discovering that this is a more
sustainable form of meat you know to
grow the cells in cell culture and uh
they are reporting that it has the exact
same taste and you know same thing but
just very very sustainable form of meal
so who knows what will happen in 10
years
I do know too there was uh conferences
we've been involved with recently this
year with cultured meat and culture
General protein and they had cultured
caviar into taste at this the conference
too so yes I see it's coming it's going
um and it's a huge piece it's right for
sustainable food products absolutely
yeah I mean we we focus mainly on
disease and everything but also for
sustainable healthy living in the next
few years cell culture is going to have
a very important role I think yeah I
agree with you that's
okay let's go to my questions list two
so we've got another one um Ernesto
well actually all of you are in a
different phase in your in your career
we know this
um and it's great to have such a wide
array of panelists here but
um in your journey as careers scientists
what do you feel are your career
aspirations for 10 years from now for
yourself
so not what the world can do like as a
whole but what do you want to be doing
in 10 years
well I I do hope that is still doing
some uh uh very like uh Cutting Edge
technology on the on the field on
transplantation so basically uh still
the scientific
um branch of work uh in Academia or
industry I do not have any preference
but
um as long as I'm doing like very
Cutting Edge science and technology so
if I'm doing this I'm happy
that's a good way to be oh yeah
how about urukia for the next 10 years
or longer
take over the world
um
I have been thinking a lot about that
recently because I'm in that phase of
finishing up my PhD and you know
planning my next career trajectory
um and so I think for myself because I
currently work on a clinical trial I
would want to be in a position where I
take the work we do in cell culture and
directly take that to the patients so of
course in cancer research
um the basic science that we do is to
find you know the mechanisms that might
drive the cancer and so I would
potentially want to be I guess say a
project manager for a breast cancer
clinical trial
um using new Cutting Edge resources and
Technology
that can you know help us to find what
these mechanisms are and to treat the
patients in real time
um I think I also want in that sphere
increase diversity and representation in
clinical trials
um so that everyone benefits from the
research that we're doing
um I think I also want to open a
mentorship program
alongside that to encourage other young
women to get into stem
um train them in cell culture train them
how to do science and just encourage
them to you know get into this field
because we have to make space as we move
along for the upcoming generation yeah I
love that I love that
so in a in a little bit of a different
way to look at it if you could look back
at your self 10 years ago
and look at where you are now do you
feel you are in the spot you expected
yourself to be in is it better worse or
exactly what you thought I'm gonna stick
with you here what do you think
um my plan so I grew up in Guyana and I
think coming from there the two careers
that your parents
always special on you is you either be a
lawyer or a medical doctor so growing up
I had no idea what a scientist was I
mean I took science courses and I was
taught by teachers but as scientist I
had no idea what that was
um and so
looking back no I would have never
imagined myself here it's not until I
came to the US and I attended undergrad
that I worked in a research lab and I
saw okay
I can do science and my interest in
curiosity for the way life Works can
actually be made into a career
um and so even while I was in undergrad
I was applying to medical schools I had
taken the MCAT course I had even
submitted my primary applications to
medical school and then after I
completed a internship I said you know
what I think
I want to be at the Forefront of
creating knowledge and not just applying
it in the clinic and so in that moment I
would Drew my applications and then I
submitted applications to grad school
and so here I am who would have thought
and that's a great step too it it is a
world of difference to be creating your
new I mean you're answering your own
hypotheses right then you have the
opportunity to do that and go explore
um what you have questions about that
have maybe affected your personal life
too I know you have
you have those in your history I I mean
in your snapshot in a bottle you've
talked about that and your mom and so it
I know it means a lot to you so it's
wonderful to hear that
yes absolutely because I think
um
the whole purpose of going to you know
medical school is because I wanted to
help patients like my mother but then I
realized that
even if I did want to help them they
were still alive in the amount of help I
can give because they're
we first have to make the discovery of
what is happening in those patients and
then create a therapy signaled to them
and then when I had met with an actual
oncologist you know he told me you know
sadly their mother's stage there isn't
much what could be done but through
research and scientific discovery we can
make Headway and I think that was my
defining moment of realizing the
importance of research
yeah it's a very motivational meaningful
story that you have thank you for
sharing that
okay Amit I'm putting you on the spot
what about you if you look back 10 years
are you where you imagine you so
so so basically you know I started with
this with the typical uh you know like
how 90 of the people approach it I am
going to do a PhD then I'm going to do a
postdoc for a few years and then I will
get the experience I will join the
industry then I will uh mint money and
live in a big mansion you know so this
is basically how everybody thinks how
everybody you know like has some kind of
an aspiration you know but you know what
surprised me the most is uh when I uh
finished my PhD and while my PhD and
during my postdoc and all this research
career I discovered how much joy it is
to make discoveries and to troubleshoot
things and apart from that one of my
biggest Joys has been uh to be a part of
a teaching institution in which I got to
Mentor a lot of undergraduate students a
lot of medical students
from very diverse countries very diverse
backgrounds you know underrepresented
minorities and to inculcate in them
somewhere a love for Science and the
love for Discovery you know that you how
to ask questions how to approach them
how to design experiments so you know
working in a lab is no longer a stepping
stone to go to med school you know for
several of the students you know but to
seriously consider science as a form of
career because we need more scientists
we need more scientific funding and we
need a bigger scientific infrastructure
to truly make difference in the
healthcare world to understand diseases
to develop new treatments so this is
something that has been an eye-opener
for me
in the past 10 years so I would say it
has been a very satisfying experience
and in certain aspects it has totally
exceeded what my expectations were and I
have never been happier to be a part of
this oh that's that's awesome that's
even better that it's it exceeded
expectations
and Ernesto how about
help and forward
to today
well well I was listening to to rookia
and I I considered myself uh 10 years uh
uh ago because I was in the in a very
defining moment for me to deciding
whether or not should I pursue this uh
the scientific career and then uh trying
to find a spot for me to perform uh and
doing the scientists the science that I
wanted to develop and uh having to make
a decision to go back to my country and
decided to do this uh this
um development of my career in my home
country though so so this is very
satisfying for me to to see uh this
story from Rukia and
um and I mean for now I think I think I
can say that I am where I was planning
to be where uh 10 years ago but it was
not a straight line it was a very very
like a roller coaster experience you
know we have to be a very resilient as
scientists it's a it's not a very like
um
homogeneous experience but as for me
it's uh it's a very satisfying uh
overall uh career I mean like Ahmed said
there is uh we are passionate about the
discovery we're passionate about the
unknown so we are want to expand the
knowledge of human uh uh
from the frontiers of human knowledge so
this is very uh challenging so this is
very inspiring but it's not it's not
easy it's a it takes a lot of us it
takes a lot of sacrifice resilience to
go that
true it's true
that's really that it's firing here
because you you've all not I'll just put
it this way I I grew up in the United
States in Buffalo New York and this is
where I still live and it's nice that
there's a global view on this panel as
well too I don't I don't have that
global view as well as you all do and so
it's um it's really nice to to hear
those those thoughts so you you imagine
one way it's going to be and then it's
there's changes in roller coasters and I
think that happens to all of us uh it
certainly happened to me as well so
thank you for that
um I am going to add on another couple
of questions too I'm I'm curious now
that we've been chatting do you find
that there is a general shared knowledge
that is accessible in your field of
research do you think that there is
something that needs to be built as a
better way to share and expand knowledge
of things that are going on I know we
have published papers and journals and
things like that but is there something
that you use or something you wish we
had in the world
um to share information and research
anything outside of what already exists
today
that's open for anyone because
I don't want to put anyone on the spot
this is a
a curious question for me
um if I can answer that from my
understanding I think maybe not in the
sense of between researchers but the
access between researchers and the
public because the science that we do is
not a lot just for ourselves you know we
do this to help the people in the world
helping everyone and I think you know
even for myself when I think about it
um sometimes I get you know a lot of
questions from my own family about
finance and research and then there's so
much misinformation that they've told me
and I'm like no not exactly so what if
there was a way that scientists as a
whole made now we made our work much
more accessible to the public in a way
that's easy for them to understand
almonds also break down the barriers of
some of the distrust that maybe some
communities have about science because
we saw that with covet you know the
mistress
and I think
in a way as we do the science we need to
immediately make it more accessible and
understandable for public consumption
I think that's a great that is a very
great point and you're right through
covid too there was a lot of information
spread
um and scientists speaking to
non-scientists let's just put it that
way in the easiest way and it is I got a
lot of questions from family members too
um in the same kind of thing it was just
words spoken that weren't quite
understood what it means or the
implications of of vaccines and things
like that and so it's a great point
to share it and maybe there's something
Thermo can do to help with that too so
we appreciate that feedback
we do have a question from the audience
I will read it
um networking and oh unless I'm sorry
unless Ernesto and Amite wanted to say
anything more about that
I didn't mean to skip over you did you
have you wanted to add to that last
question
Ernesto go ahead
all right I think it was going on and uh
okay
yes sorry I think we have a little a
little delay sorry for that and uh but I
I just want to say that rookie was very
spot on on the um science indication I
think we need to improve our
communication to broader Society
to avoid misguidancing especially in
terms of policy making and uh in a
broader sense of population education I
think we have to uh I think covet shows
us that we have to uh pursue this path
in a more uh uh a better way let's say
let's put it that and uh not in terms of
communication but I think in the
representation as well I think science
needs more representative
representativity not only on the career
side but also on data as well uh I mean
we have like a lot of Technology a lot
of money being put on on very Cutting
Edge genetic
studies and and therapy studies but uh
the representation of it is very limited
to 12 countries in and not for
developing countries and this is very
exclusive excluded in terms of health
and future approaches to treat human
diseases yeah yeah
thank you
I think
both made excellent points and uh I want
to add just one more thing like as
important as science communication is to
uh convey the facts to the lay
population through different platforms I
think it is also important that in the
scientific Community also they make some
of the study some of the papers easier
to understand like in the past few years
they have papers with so much data so
much figures crammed in it that it's
almost impossible to understand you know
what's the take-home message of this
paper so maybe there needs to be some
kind of a communication
that would simplify the way the data is
represented like I am from the cancer
field you know so sometimes infectious
diseases are very uh you know
neurosurgery or neurology or something I
don't understand those things so but it
should be easy that you know when I'm
reading a paper like if I'm writing a
paper someone who's not from my field
should also be able to understand them
so this this kind of communication also
matters and the second important thing
is uh accessibility because people there
are scientific researchers scientific
community in the different parts of the
world and the world is shrinking now as
a technology is growing so I think there
should be more Open Access and there
should be more accessibility you know
like paying all these crazy subscription
fees you know for journals
someone in developing country will not
have the access to that so it's there
should be an equitable distribution that
everybody can access scientific
information in a proper and fair way so
that's what I think yeah
we agree
thank you for that
in the chat I will
the first one
is there anything that you really wish
you could do today with your current
research but are limited by available
technology and tools for example what is
the specific capability you wish that
you had that would accelerate your
research right now that maybe you don't
have available technology and tools for
maybe your dream tool or technology that
would that would enhance your research
that you don't have
anybody it's open to anybody
is it an instrument or some software
that does math for you
well I I think it's it's a very hard
question uh I'm sorry hotel I have to I
don't know why but I have this delay
sorry for for jumping but uh I think
this is a a very tricky question because
every time that I dream all week it
would be interesting if we had this
technology on the very next day there's
a paper published on nature and or so on
showing the same thing so the science is
evolving so fast on this so for me it's
very hard to say this because all the
tools that I I I wish we had for like
five years ago we already have so this
is a is a fantastic time to be a
scientist in our field
um when I think about my own I want to
oh
good good go ahead go ahead Rukia okay
um one of the things now that I'm trying
to do with my research is a type of
Technology called long-range composing
and so a few companies offer this but
the issue is because it's Whole New
World
platforms and programs to absolutely
analyze those and so in a way it's more
so if you think about like aluminum and
like regular sequencing so when a
patient comes into the clinic you try to
sequence their genome
um and then you try to find the markers
or mutations that that patient might
have
um but there were certain limitations
with that type of sequencing because in
the clinic what we have found is that a
lot of the drivers
um for certain cancers are in the
portions of DNA that the current
technology would toss away in the
introns and exons so there are certain
Junctions that they may not include and
so there is a new technology long-range
sequencing that we're now trying to do
on patient samples and I have done that
but I just have the data sitting there
because of course I'm not a
computational biologist so I have no
idea how to analyze this data
um there isn't much on the internet
um we're in the scientific world that
does human patients
um with this type of sequencing so I
think in the future the technology that
I think would be helpful is a platform
where you can
Analyze This quickly
um and then
more technology to better analyze the
entire deep I mean genome or DNA of
patients that will not miss these
alterations or mutations
and I'm sure you're not alone
in that
all right Ami you had something to say
too right
yes uh recently
um I I did experiments using the Nano
string platform and I was flabbergasted
I had so many genes and all big data
waiting and I didn't know how to do the
analysis I had no access to our
programming because it was not a thing
back in the day
so we had to track down
bioinformaticians statistician and then
basically learn on the job you know how
to do it and make sense out of what data
I had so I think as time goes by I think
it would be nice to
have access to better bioinformatics
tools on a serious note because now like
you know it's everything is rna-c can
you know all the big data analysis so uh
I hope there are like simpler tools for
everyone to have so I hope that's what
we will have in the future and on a
lighter note I think science makes the
progress to have a robot that can do the
lab dishes
the dishes not the culturing the dishes
got it the dishes
I thought you were going to say the
culturing the passaging
which might not be actually out of the
out of sight pretty soon we might have
that
all right thank you there's there's a
couple more questions
um this one networking and collaboration
are drivers of Discovery in scientific
Fields what partnership have you
uncovered that was particularly helpful
to you or what type of collaboration
partnership are you looking for in the
future
uh I will go with Ernesto
well um despite the classic strategy for
collaboration in uh science where you
can look out for um colleagues of yours
of yours working with different fields
and different skills that are
complementary to the the question
they're trying to answer I found myself
in the past years uh very uh well suited
with collaborations in partnership with
the industry and especially with
startups and also big companies as well
because uh those small companies they
they drive their their business through
very Innovative approaches and
Technologies and they they need to test
those Technologies in a very um unique
setup of research and experimentation so
I think this is um I think there's a a
boom of startups in the field and I
think this uh this approach to try to
make collaborations with of these
players in the market I think this has
been very helpful for me most recently
very good
either one of you want to add
uh yes I think collaborations are and
networking it's very very important
because uh you know sometimes you have
some kind of experimental idea in your
head but you don't know how to go about
it and then you go to a conference you
go to a meeting and uh you know you
might see a talk or you might go and see
a vendor and you will say oh hey this is
something I can use and I go to uh I go
to the American Association for
Immunology meeting every year and I come
back with my head filled with like 1000
different ideas on how I can approach
things
so that kind of networking that goes on
in conferences or meetings or something
that you learn through webinars that is
very very important because you have to
keep an open mind the question or the
experiment that you want to do is the
most important thing the technique is
just a tools and the techniques how to
go about it you can achieve by proper
networking or just going about your
institution or asking questions and
um in in my career I have met people who
have been kind enough to help me out and
I have learned so many new things and
answered all the scientific questions I
had thanks to networking and
collaboration so there can be no science
without collaboration and collaboration
is a very integral part of science
that's what I think yeah absolutely I
totally agree
Rukia do you want to add anything to
that
um in terms of collaboration I think you
know it has in the beginning driven my
progress and my PhD
um especially if you know as a person I
can't do everything and so
handing off maybe a side project or an
experiment to someone has been helpful
um in the future however ones that I
mostly looking for collaborating with
maybe even committees where I'm able to
play a role in increasing diversity in
clinical trials because you know as I
mentioned before
um the work that we do in the lab in our
cell culture a lot of it we hope is
translational to saving real lives
um and there is a huge deficit in the
diversity of patiental Trials and so one
of the things I hope to collaborate with
or even with companies you know
um going out into the community where we
one educate the public and then to make
it make sure that they trust us in a way
where they have the faith to participate
in these clinical trials for cancer
discovery that we're doing
I love it and I sense a really nice
theme coming from
all right we've got another question
um and I'm going to start with you um uh
because this was it's about a PhD so it
says how does cell culture research
differ for those who do not have a PhD
and those who do for example Masters
will allow more technical learning while
a PhD opens a gateway to research do you
feel there's a difference there how does
cell culture research difference between
PhD and non-phd researchers
um I don't
that's kind of an open-ended question
because it depends on what field you're
in if I can think about it there are a
few
students who do um pursue Masters
um who are exposed to cell culture work
um but maybe in a way the technical part
can come into you know in a PhD a lot of
times you're responsible for creating
the knowledge and taking charge of your
own project whereas maybe in a masters
it's more guided and you have a strict
um path to follow so that's the only
difference that I can think of but for
those students who might not have a PhD
as in
no Masters or anything at all maybe they
don't have access to cell culture if I'm
understanding the question correctly
um but there are a few Master's students
who I know are engaged in cell culture
I've trained a few of them in my lab
um so I don't think there's a vast
difference the only thing would come in
project management and driving your own
research as a PhD where you're much more
independent versus a Masters or maybe
even a bachelor's where you're maybe
told exactly what to do
yep that makes sense
okay let me Ernesto oh yep I want to say
yep
yes
I have a lot to say on that actually
so there is no no difference between a
PhD and a master student or even an
undergrad when you work in a lab you are
either a good pair of hands technically
or a bad Pair of Hands I have seen uh
people who are PhD or postdocs or
something who are horrible at cell
culture cannot maintain anything to save
their lives and there are lab techs and
there are undergrads who are excellent
at it you know so it it all depends on
how you are as a person and your own
skills education and all this is cell
culture is something that is learned
through experience that someone teaches
you how you imbibe and it is a very very
technical thing how good is your
Technique so
this is a Level Playing Field
irrespective of your degree you are as
good as what you learn and how you
implement your learning in in on the lab
bench
all right I love the way you look at
that that's yeah I just I just want to
yeah I just wanted to add that to what
comment said the degree uh matters the
least on this subject it's what we like
in pilots in Airplane pliers is the time
of flight it's how much time and and
training have you put in to to use your
skills in our in our in our field not
time of flight but time in culturehood
so how much time you spent there and the
success you have will build upon that
love to think about it that way yep
because we've got we've got folks coming
from all sorts of backgrounds and all
sorts of levels of experience too
we meet them all the time
yeah well please go ahead
I have a very interesting anecdote okay
if I want if I may share for a couple of
days a couple of minutes sorry uh I have
a very very non-orthodox method like uh
people will ask how did you learn cell
culture I have a very very non-orthodox
way how I learned cell culture okay so
when I had joined the lab I had never
even pipetted anything and I had a so in
PhD you know you had to do lab rotation
in different labs and everything
so I've internet did a lab rotation so
in that lab rotation actually the master
student was my friend from India and she
was like a no-nonsense person you know
and she was very experienced in cell
culture and everything
so I had to grow cells okay and I would
be like she would be like no you have to
do this slowly she was very strict with
me so I remember I used to be in the
hood and she used to sit on one of those
high chairs next to me and in cell
culture you know the liquid nitrogen you
have this big foot ruler that you have
for measuring the liquid nitrogen levels
so she would take that and she would
keep it next to me okay so if I did
anything bad she would poke me with it
like you do not touch this you do not do
that you know so she would poke me with
that stick
and then I knew what not to do but it
was very funny and we were friends and
you know she was doing this out of humor
but her constant yelling taught me how
what not to do in cell culture and you
know this is how I learned how to do
proper cell culture technique well it's
good there's not a lot of people
there's a lot of stuff that you're not
allowed to do in cell culture it's very
true
all right uh we have no further
questions I wonder if any of you three
have any last comments you'd like to
share before we close out
if not I have some but if anyone wanted
to share anything anything more
I want to say one thing uh most likely
an experiment uh most likely an
experiment rather than it working the
way you want it to it will not work the
way you want it to so have faith in
yourself have faith in your work and
keep trying and troubleshoot and
ultimately you will succeed so never
lose hope and
it's it's very true because a failed
experiment still teaches you a whole lot
right so
we really appreciate all three of you
being on today we appreciate your time
your experience and sharing it with us
we've talked about a lot of things even
where we were 10 years ago where we want
to be in 10 years and how we compare and
the the need for bringing science out to
the community to everyone in the world
that the world is getting smaller and
the sharing is very important so we
appreciate all of that and I think with
that we'll bring it over to Susie to
close us out
well I also want to thank all of you
panelists for your time today and for
your important research and I'd also
like to thank labroots and our sponsor
Therma Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's webcast before we
go I want to thank our audience for
joining us today and further interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speaker via the information you
provided at the time of registration and
this webcast can be viewed on demand the
lab Roots will let you video via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care everyone and
thank you again to all of you
thank you for having me